to play that game but we have played so
long and we've done so many come back so
we always always believe in ourselves
what's crazy about the success of the
new fnatic lineup it feels like it's
really made us actually kind of take
greatness for granted because already
this is clearly one of the best csgo
teams we've ever seen fnatic under got a
very large roster change yeah the
problem this team has is the identity of
the teams has gone completely he wants
the whole team just started to tilt and
just having small arguments and everyone
start to hate small hate each other and
it broke down the team
once upon a time fanatic where the best
team in csgo recently fanatic fans were
treated to a return to glory as core
crew Crim's JW and flashes showed us
they still got what it takes with
newcomers let grow and golden of course
proving that they don't Nina olofmeister
here's the best of fnatic at I am
Katowice means he needs to take the agro
way to take a fight and he's done
exactly that two kills per Guardian as
he sits on 10 HP go for a third like
Rose gonna try and respond he's
excellent with the deagle apparently the
USB as well smoke down Crim's has the
kid he's gonna get onto it they've got a
run through Nico's gotta get onto it
sooner he doesn't know could find
absolutely everything here he's coming
behind them they have no idea
he pops out towards the connector now
he's got a great chance it's gonna do it
as he looked to his left he well he's
gonna find both with them he's going
with double notes oh my goodness he'll
get both just this single but that's
enough to win the round
definitely spots him oh not only does he
spot him thank you very much Wow
no way no way not only that he's cost a
full rotation from Ivy from rain and so
does he connect inside of Z connector
flush it gets one more kill and there's
micros got the whole map to play with
he's hoping that flush you can anchor
this position down but he has the option
to go back to a and look at flushing oh
my god this would be a horse reset on 14
rounds for fnatic and that smoke is
tantalize what he's gonna clean out
connector
it's just Nico yet again who has to try
and pull it back he's got the ak-47 some
utility in a kit to do so and lack row
is taking his sweet time to make sure he
figures this out now this is interesting
because now it's return favor
Nico's snuck around behind flush up and
he could actually spoil the whole plan
as sneakiest watch it oh my god that is
one of the most impressive clutches you
will ever see my god who flushed out
what was that an ace is well to do it
obviously I say that but somehow he gets
Kerrigan through it that's great from
lag crow remember this is the buy where
phase is struggling was no utility and
let goes picking them limb from limb my
goodness
that clue that is beautiful
counter-strike showing how much skill
this young man has against flusher who
wanted to get aggressive because of the
HP could find from JW they don't worry
is what JW's quick his third in the
round it's not versus often Guardian has
been absolutely electric in all of this
series but GW is certainly on to it now
Guardians tapped it doesn't matter JW's
earned it and an incredible fashion
Moff is gonna try and challenge screams
if anyone knows how he's gonna play it
that's the man on phase that yes that's
a good comments but it comes Crim's now
how has he done that again it looked
like he was done for one kill sure but
not two of them necro good so far but he
can't have any vision you're right no
vision but he goes aggressive we saw it
from twist yesterday does the same thing
and the deagle through the box works as
well he knows now that those smokes
actually worked in his favor back
through lead the charge with support of
guardians electro the double faced
double spray with the a k he slays them
all and gets the round for Vinayak such
a great start of a fantastic the CT
Cyberman as he got into the game Crim's
with the opening track JW scientific
sharp thoughts he surely has taken down
here but Norway's Crim's is there ready
wasted to protect his teammate three
kills with him he'll go down but it's
still a very clean round to pick up the
a K and now we have it's it's waiting
Russia gives the first kill Guardians
gonna go down 23:09 oh dear five on
three now but Niko does get one back
does he know it like throw needs to be
swift about this he needs to be calm it
needs to be still at all there's nerve
he does exactly that a cake wrapped this
becomes very awkward for all often brain
brain locked in the corners well GW is
gonna confirm that and they've running
ton not only do they get the kill they
do it convincingly all off last man
alive has an ak-47 to him what a time
for like her to double his kill score
and flush against the shot on body
you're right beginning of the end in dg2
unfortunately
Oh mom still towards middle hitchhike
normal phase overextended no one getting
bit aggressive gada trying to see if you
can mimic the sound of the palm plant or
the pumping chopped apologies smoke
towards CT Eagle certainly could cause
some damage do flashbangs everything
about a position I've been smart out of
this and these for three or four players
they're flashable strike first is still
can all fall apart
here we go fnatic stepping up with the
pistols and steel has got nothing to do
in this round so if there's no one there
GW that's great positioning is it a sort
of double bookstore's Walker put his
movement deterred by the fact that
someone stood on his head and yet fell
in front of the Alpha terrorist team
liquid certainly with the upper hand
here as JW starts hitting shots like
that that's lovely now if I though
response to on sunau bomb ticking away
and fillet liquid have done enough there
as JW finds another steel is exposed
from B and he'll have to hit this short
he does but JW with the AWP was absent
in the first half but he makes
everything happen in the second three
kills from the ruins Wow 23 kills for
Crim's as it gets for in this round that
puts him at the top to mention that he
started off last rounded style as well
he is so so good on Mirage and it's
coming to spades now as its fnatic you
with not much left in their way and get
down us another sick deagle shot and
they keep challenging him there he'll
hit shots for days try to go that deagol
pick at the start certainly was
successful what a beautiful shot that
was never a better time to wake up
well it might not be done just yet one
versus one Nikko versus flusher ammo
Nico of no armor ticks are made to the
face there smoking towards the bathroom
and flush up oh my goodness so
aggressive goes past him in a smoke and
he takes him down smoke to allow them to
at least attempt chips to get to the
site and maybe get home plant down this
time his cluster gets involved with the
a.k jumping over smart mechanic actually
pulls out of the jump because he would
have no chance to fire a Cartier
actually
not only destroys Guardian but finds
Nico as well every single crevice of the
beatbox eye drops the smoke knows no
point being silent all that will give it
up oh how is he doing this I gotta to
get three rounds excuse me three kills 9
HP Golden's just gotten in position with
and that need could have easily killed
either of them in a lob what's gone the
flight guess who's ready and guess who's
waiting Olaf slows down he knows they're
softened up goes for the first kill does
he expect oh no he does not
Russia with four in an incredible
fashion all on low HP clearing it he's
trying to get a rough idea of what's up
he's going on the first crack goes their
way but Nico hits it with the assault
and battery but it's not going to work
out well flush it with the trade to prax
the site control taken like friends will
do what he can here golden it's up to
him three versus two they have time it
makes its way towards the site nails to
shop at Guardian still alive and kicking
the low HP does not matter but now he
has zero Nico one versus one with JW
bomb planted and he knows it eats low he
picks up the m4 and said this Chadha
strongly his and he does it
JW delivers white when his team needs
him too much shots and fluster
capitalizing once again gets the double
kill bomb down the truck at the back
toward the a side as well especially JW
still on the AWP it's one back that's
gonna force a couple you two switches
angle but still manages to find Nico
look at Carrick and go that's not to do
much so far in this game but he's
stepping up now sliding down his
guardian and he gets wealth loose pistol
to the heads again to clutch this time
one versus two he is good at these
clutches now when his team needs and he
likes to step up especially on this
particular map Kerrigan to find the
first pup JW will quickly pick him up at
they'll just go and refund the
speciality cider
well this time Russia wants a piece of
the pie heats out gets the first somehow
grabs a second as well
me going all off down that's a pretty
good start for your first two picks
window confusing but they just walk it
in what a slaughter it is map is done no
question here comes the flash towards
full golden of the elevation angle as
you said four point one watch this watch
I'm still at the second my first two can
he does it JW electro he's gonna save
the day some what's there it is double
kill the heavens Wow three come through
his see mother trade was always sad
brave awkward was somehow he does fight
through it as well on the site groups
we've won crimson the second the
showstopper bombs in a really difficult
position for their fully committing
they're gonna spotted will they get the
kills they suddenly world Russia steps
up can't take it back I was gonna say
not quite as quick this time he
certainly is this map really lends
itself to his go sets and how many times
both it was rain by mistake I almost
daresay golden goes out of 48 the maids
are great bad nico takes both of them
that have made you can see them working
in tandem to find the first pick that's
great from fnatic still Kennedy goes
straight toward gold unfortunately for
him plus his part quicker to respond and
he gets Guardian as well perhaps that
confidence seeing his teammate run in
and got inspired but
foolishly show slow flusher
to work with toward banana tries to
spray and smoke gone flush it with the
ace gets all five he gets the triple
spray down all head shots as Giardia
we'll get him back that's surely enough
at this point as Guardium we'll take him
down 55 seconds now all of mice has no
choice but to save him and that's gonna
be actually flush up with one bomb down
45 seconds completely blind and there we
have it
fnatic pick up their pick it was an
absolute bloodbath their double overtime
or water recovery from the situation
they're in in the first half and look
there they were down and out but now
this grand final just got exciting the
box however he's gonna slide out but
Gordian again goes aggressive black bro
makes up port finally puts the AWP
player down you're right in saying that
Crim's also found to kill in the mix to
leave our switches Nico cuz Olaf
might let go as well he goes given away
his position or my goodness slack rope
Fulton and flush 1/2 to be the 2 to pull
this back to force this the distance
balm already planted thankfully and
flush it with one but he's got a lot
more to go in fact he needs another ace
just to keep fnatic alive and phase
trials and tribulations and finals and
they certainly showed through again they
might finally redeem from last year and
get their first IEM championship it only
takes one kill flush uh he's not gonna
allow that easily gets it down to two
scoring at 17 HP that gives flush to the
upper hand as well flash out he's faced
off of it forced off the angle at flush
just got us going the distance as he
hits the shot and we tied things up he's
done it again Russia waiting the smoke
skill in flashbacks deploy can make quit
find anything he'd better believe he can
takes down rain four and four Kerrigan's
taking a massive amount of damage as
well I believe from a negro
but it's blush that I could slide up you
said he needed another big one he's got
another big one 1717 Kerrigan has popped
on GW again it was a time two years ago
you would have rolled your eyes watching
fnatic win yet another event perhaps
like a fine wine it's gotten sweeter
with time because they have to warn this
one every inch of the way JW finally
silence what it's just gone
[Applause]
two full years and a legendary brand a
legendary team gets back on top and for
the third time the first ever three-time
champions and I am they'll walk to the
front of a stage they'll grab the trophy
they burned it fnatic but your IEM tell
Extreme Masters kind of into Champions
in 2018
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]